let's shift a little bit to the question
of buying sperm right so tell us a
little bit about the prices paid by
people who buy sperm I presume there's
some markup between what the sperm donor
is paid and what they receive on the
other end absolutely these are
businesses after all for-profit
businesses the sperm donor is walking in
being paid a hundred to one hundred and
fifty dollars for that sample the sperm
bank takes that sample and can create
anywhere from zero files if the sperm
count isn't high enough - one or two -
as many as eight or nine vials from that
single sample that they've paid about a
hundred and twenty-five dollars for then
the sperm bank will turn around they
have to freeze it for six months retest
the donor for HIV and then they put that
sample on the market so there is a wide
infrastructure that's in place for
making sure that that sperm is then safe
to sell and so the sperm banks they have
a number of costs that they're trying to
manage however when they turn around and
sell those vials they're selling them
for five hundred six hundred seven
hundred dollars depending on the
specific characteristics of the sperm
those are technical characteristics for
somebody who would like to purchase
sperm in order to try to have a child
they rarely get pregnant on the first
time and you're buying multiple vials
and so this can very quickly add up to
be quite an expensive proposition and
one not typically covered by health
insurance or anything else right correct
him and tell me a little bit about how
the way in which individual sperm donors
are marketed to families who are
thinking about using a sperm donor what
kinds of information about the sperm
donor are typically provided yeah well
this has really changed over time so
sperm donation has more than a century
of history behind it and for most of the
20th century it was very anonymous very
secretive and it was really the doctors
who were in charge the doctor would pick
somebody actually be a sperm donor right
away in some cases the ledge used his
own sperm and stuff like that exactly
there have certainly been cases of that
legal cases of that so what would
typically happen is a couple a
heterosexual couple would come in and
say to the doctor we've had trouble
getting pregnant they would be evaluated
and then the doctor would go into the
next room pull a medical resident or a
medical student off the floor ask them
to provide a sample it was then fresh
insemination all right so with the
advent of AIDS in the 1980s this became
no longer tenable and sperm banks
started these
you know businesses with the freezing
and the shipping and the evaluations and
the screening and all of that so over
time the amount of information about the
donor and also the consumers agency in
this process has really increased so now
if you go to a sperm bank you'll get you
know twenty five to fifty pages of
information about that donor at the
health history and answers to all kinds
of questions like what was your favorite
book as a child why do you want to be a
donor
you know describe your hair and your
skin and your height and your menu like
dexterity right so all of these
questions are now made available to
consumers who can click through and
decide what kind of characteristics that
they want in their donor are there
particular traits that are particularly
valued you'd have paid more for by the
sperm bank or particularly valued by
consumers yeah and so this is another
interesting difference that emerges when
you're looking at sperm banks versus egg
agencies and so sperm banks have a
number of requirements that really
reflect our cultural expectations for
masculinity so sperm donors have to be
at least five feet eight or five feet
nine inches tall short sperm doesn't
sell men have to be enrolled in college
or have a four-year degree and if you
then switch over to the egg agencies
they don't have that same height
requirement they don't have that same
education requirement so we know that
your height and your education does not
appear in any one place on your DNA but
that you inherit elements of those
characteristics from both parents and so
why do we need tall educated sperm
donors but we don't need tall educated
egg donors and I think that's one of the
places where when you compare these two
markets you can really see cultural
norms around gender emerging and
infusing the way that the market
operates so what about ethnicity are
there particular ethnicity --zz that are
harder to find in the market or the
premiums paid for some ethnicities well
this again is another difference between
sperm banks and egg agencies so sperm
banks will pay the same rate to all of
the men in the bank there are some banks
that in the past have paid extra for men
with PhDs but in terms of ethnicity
sperm banks will really just complain
about the difficulty they have in
recruiting men from a diverse range of
backgrounds so they might bend their
expectations in terms of those height
requirements or their education
requirements in order to get men from a
diverse array of backgrounds in the door
and egg agencies they
we do pay women more if they come from
racial or ethnic backgrounds that they
consider hard to recruit so
african-american women donors Asian
American women donors will often command
a few thousand dollars more than white
donors and that's interesting
sociological a because this is one of
the few markets where women of color do
better than white women in terms of
labor market outcomes that's fascinating
yeah can you talk a little bit about the
differences between anonymous versus
open identification sperm banks yeah so
again this is sort of a historical shift
in the early days of sperm donation as I
mentioned it was completely anonymous
secretive often records weren't even
capped so certainly recipients had no
idea who the donor was and vice-versa
and this really shifted along with
demographic changes in the number of
same-sex couples so there was a sperm
bank that grew out of the feminist
women's health movement and they were
really oriented to serving the lesbians
and single women in the late 70s early
80s who were barred from mainstream
sperm banks so mainstream sperm banks
would not send sperm to lesbians or
single women saying that they didn't
actually have infertility so this you
know feminist oriented sperm bank opens
up and they start selling sperm to
lesbians and single women who said it'd
be really great if we could find out
more about our donor or maybe our
children could meet the donor someday so
the very first what they call identity
release program opened in around 1980
1981 and that became something that then
migrated to more mainstream sperm banks
as the mainstream sperm banks became
more open to serving these same sex
couples and single women that they had
previously been discriminating against
are there any noticeable difference
these days between the ways in which
lesbian women are single women select
sperm donors as opposed to heterosexual
couples so the number of heterosexual
couples who have to go to sperm banks to
treat their infertility is actually
dramatically reduced and that happened
after the development of XE ICSI which
is intracytoplasmic sperm injection in
the mid 1990s this is a technology that
if they could find a single sperm in the
male body they could inject it directly
into the egg and so heterosexual couples
that can afford IVF with ixy now really
prefer that technology because it allows
them to have a genetically related child
so this is that shift I was talking
about where the sperm banks were mostly
serving heterosexual clients
saw that population drop in the 90s they
start opening up their doors to the
lesbians and single women when I talked
to the sperm bank owners and people who
work in sperm banks they say absolutely
that the considerations are different
for heterosexual couples and lesbians
lesbians have no reason to hide the fact
that they needed to purchase sperm
whereas heterosexual couples were really
focused on trying to match the husband's
physiognomies in order to make sure that
people didn't guess that he wasn't the
real father so this sort of secrecy and
anonymity along with the demographics of
the customers have really changed how
this market works
tell us a little bit about the
international market for sperm so one
thing I've read is that actually Danish
sperm is particularly exported yes so
this is the phenomenon of the Viking
sperm banks so the Denmark is actually
the largest exporter of sperm in the
world they have a website that is
festooned with little blonde blue-eyed
babies and this is the idea that they
really have sperm that people want and
part of why Denmark has become such a
large exporter of sperm is because
several of the other European countries
have exerted quite a lot of regulation
on sperm banks and sperm donation so one
example here is France it's a national
sperm bank a nationalized sperm bank but
they only allow heterosexual couples
access to sperm so lesbians and single
women in France then need to turn
elsewhere so this is part of the market
that the Viking sperm bank is serving
great and just to pick two things out of
that one is it seems to be there's a bit
of a eugenic impulse and we'll talk
about this at a later portion of the
course right certain traits are valued
or thought to be valued the other this
idea of trying to circumvent domestic
regulation by importing right so they
don't like the way in which France
regulates sperms if we're a lesbian
couple they may import sperm from
Denmark rather than dealing with the
French authorities in their regulation
right exactly well the last thing one
asked about its sperm is we've talked a
lot about sperm donation in the sense of
man who sells sperm and people who buy
sperm how are things different at all
between true donation altruistic
donation if you will well one of the
really interesting elements of this
market that has been emerging in the
last few years is really due to Internet
traffic and sperm so there's been a
couple of journalistic expose
of men who offer their sperm online for
free to all comers and so this is an
example of altruistic a sperm donation
I'm not sure if it's quite the type that
you were asking me about but that is a
completely unknown underbelly of this
market and we are just starting sort of
sociological and anthropological studies
of how that market is operating and
later in this course we'll actually talk
about the case of the Craigslist sperm
donor who the state of Kansas went after
for child support and that'll be
something we'll talk about which is
great